the repercussions of racism on American
society by Horrigan Jamar plastered to
John Steinbeck has touched on many
racial ideologies in his book of my men
he includes many races quotes and
actions to portray the mists children
are black into early 1900 some instances
are why in she wanted let me ask cuz I'm
black from page 68
listen she said you know what I
can do if you open your trap break 80
and this is just a talkin and I
bust your back so don't mean
nothin three a great 71
as you can see time back has included a
lot of racist comments in the book and
they pretty much all portray the same
thing
blacks were heavily discriminated at the
time and many white people were outer
douchebags but to really understand that
full meaning of this racist quotes we
need to dive back deep in time racism is
Mac that has been occurring for many
centuries in America racism has existed
EMS for backup to Egyptian to live from
1550 to 1175 of BCE in America racism
first heart of slavery Jamestown was one
of the first towns implement slavery and
a slow start to the south as it gets
class slaves had had enough and may
attempted to escape but that only led to
more punishment these slaves were
generally characterized their brutality
degradation and in community whipping
executions and rapes were commonplace
additionally these slaves didn't get
many educational opportunities as white
people and plus many were illiterate to
make matters worse medical care was very
limited this horrible mistreatment was
all de jure racism and white people spot
of superiority over black people slaves
and abolitionists believe that the
abolition of slavery whippin end to this
harsh treatment to black however it only
fueled that hate that whites in the
south already had against black people
and I drove down to the scrimmage
against these people even more once the
manger patient Proclamation and civil
war passed these black people were
finally free from the pressures hands of
slavery however they were far from free
of the handcuffs of racism in the late
1800s and early 1900s
things weren't much there for these
people there we even lost cash to
discriminate against these people such
as Black Codes which limit black rights
by using loopholes and in the end
segregate them from the whites they also
implemented many policies in order to
stop black people from voting such as
requiring full taxes and literacy discs
many states even went to extreme price
just to get discriminated these four
people for example in 1914 Louisiana
requires separate entrance for blacks
and whites in 1915 Oklahoma segregated
telephone boot and later on prohibited
integrated boxing matches several laws
like these were made and put into action
in the ears to follow these people were
even segregated in day to day life tests
such as in water fountain bathrooms
public transport and much more they
received no respect and were often
looked down upon to make things worse
employers would not even consider hiring
a black person and if they did they
would be paid significantly less white
people would often insult them like who
is life stood in this she said
you know what I can do to you if you
open your trap compared JD these insults
only put blacks down and made it
impossible for them to advance forward
in society in the end things only got
worse for them and they only gets
community even more unfortunately
insults like these were acceptable to be
said by white people with black people
at the time people hope that time pass
and this new loss to the Civil Rights
Act of 1964 and influential specifically
I have a dream speech would bring
equality to black Americans however even
after all that there are still some
slight problems of racism here and there
racism has not been asked out as a topic
as it was in the early nineteen
hundred's a break could late 1900 where
recently is becoming very public once
again for example in 1995 only 16% of
whites and 51 percent of blacks live
with justice system
against blacks in Kazan 15 44 percent of
whites and 70 cents isn't blacks believe
the justice system is biased against
blacks that's about a four hundred and
fifty percent increase racial profiling
against blacks in a big retail stores
also prevalent for example an
investigation at CBP marketplaces on
Russia racial profiling showed the
employees kept a closer eye on black
people compared to white people where
they're more likely to shoplift they
send to shoppers white and black the
white male was never questioned while
the black male was pushing up to seven
times in some stores they this is out in
many big name stores such as Best Buy
and they all showed signs of racial
profiling against black people this is
just one of the countless examples of
racism that still linger in our society
today as a result while racism is much
less in the college today compared to
1900 there are still some racism here
and there this is why we must explore
the root racism in order to be able to
fully understand the meaning of
Steinbeck's novel now that we have a
better understanding of racism 1932 we
can better understand how it was
acceptable at the time for village life
white woman was also a wife of the owner
son had superiority over quote a black
man happens back on knowledge is crucial
today because in today's study even
racial profiling authorities consider
outrageously racist as a result racism
for creating the book scenes of the
world in today's standards this is why
background knowledge about the social
situation during the time in which the
book is based on an official to be able
to fully understand nominal
researching about the time period we are
able to see those during this time
period
white women had power over black men and
superiority that white women professors
were allowed coolest life to express
negative behavior and make the wrong
erases comments that she made towards
cooks this behavior on quotes was
actually quite normal and acceptable
then sometimes black people had rebelled
such win focus that nature you've got no
right to come in a colored man's room
you got no erection messing around in
here at all
complete date however test for billion
island led to white people making
additional racist comments and putting
block people back in their place when
first reading this book kalisch why
seems like a racist comeback warrants
attention but after doing research and
they're able to see how she was just an
average white woman grieving over not
being able to achieve something that you
wanted through the core whoops into
restrictions that existed during that
time period this change in perception
conveys down born knowledge of the
social situation at the time in which a
book is based on love sense and better
understand and even accept from behavior
and comments that may seem unacceptable
in today's society we are able to better
understand the meaning behind the racist
language and decide for a Steinbeck's
motive line for train curly slice as
arrogant and racist and characterizing
hooks as extremely humble and modest
for example standby and protocol his
wife's raises comment to emphasize how
rude and mean py people were against
black people interpret rate unacceptable
show or situations that existed in
society at the time included Kooks
backing off to show how that was only
option he had and how his officer
limited due to racism overall background
knowledge about the time period which of
mice and men is based upon changed
readers perception by giving the more
insight into normal and acceptable
behavior in social situations during the
time this helps them to better
understand and interpret and messages
and motors behind characters actions
behaviors and comments in the novel in
the end and we understand these motives
about such powerful issues like racism
we are not only able to appreciate the
knowledge even more that are also able
to better appreciate inner life
[Music]
you